what viral moment in Mission Impossible
Fallout was totally improvised and how
did the director react
Henry Cavill is well known for his
Devotion to each role he takes on
whether it's being faster than a
speeding bullet as Superman to grumbling
his way through a fantasy world as
geralt of Rivia on The Witcher he knows
how to give his all in every role and
genuinely applies himself to every
single party accepts in Mission
Impossible Fallout the actor took on the
character of August Walker a CIA hire
tasked with keeping an eye on the entire
impossible missions Force through their
special activities division that puts
Walker on a collision course with
death-defying Ethan Hunt a member of the
IMF and head of a globetrotting tech
loving unit of Misfits and Rogues you're
not getting rid of me that easily huh
that's not what this is about after a
film filled with Daring Do the two men
fight it out via a helicopter duel then
battled to the death on the edge of a
cliff naturally it's Walker who meets
his maker instead of hunt while Walker
chases hunt up the sheer side of the
rock formation he smashed in the eye
with some of the rigging attached to one
of the disabled helicopters when it
comes on moored from the rock face he
falls into the explosion caused by the
now dislodged helicopter as it hits the
ground leaving hunt to scramble to
safety there's another more iconic
moment cavill's character took part in
one that he admits he's seen discuss
multiple times on Reddit and you may not
be surprised to learn that he improvised
that bit of on-screen action it turns
out his sense of humility and his wicked
sense of humor were both factors in
birthing the moment to life here's what
he says about the iconic moment he
improvised during a very memorable fight
scene during the film hunt and Walker
are involved in a bathroom wall as
Walker approaches his opponent he seems
to be pumping his arms reloading his
biceps as if they were guns the moment
became something of an online meme
during an October 2022 appearance on the
podcast happy sad confused Cavill
admitted that the moment was an
unscripted improvisation he came up with
off the cuff saying it was a rather
intense fight scene we'd actually been
shooting it for about three weeks at
that stage which is a long time in
comparison to things like The Witcher
where you get a day everything starts to
get quite sore after a while because
it's just a lot of repetitive motion the
connective tent is my biceps were
getting sore and so I had to warm them
up before I threw punches I'd literally
do that to warm them up he added in the
podcast I did it once and I thought oh
God that probably looked really stupid I
can't believe I did that I said sorry
McHugh I won't do that again the caval's
surprise the director didn't seem to
have a problem with the gesture Cavill
said then I did another take without
doing it and he's like why didn't you do
that thing that was really good and I
was like that was good he said yes
definitely do that do that and so and so
we did then Henry Cavill is no stranger
to thinking on the Fly while on set he
told Digital Spy ahead of the release of
the second season of The Witcher in 2021
that to better avoid missing a critical
character moment from the novel Series
in which garot communes with death
Cavill inserted some of that dialogue
into a different scene Cavill told
Digital Spy that he used some of the
novel's dialogue from that scene in the
moment where geralt deals with the death
of his horse Roach
afraid of her
because she is your friend caval told
Digital Spy I thought it was such a
shame that we missed that beat in the
story it's such an informative beat as
to geralt's personality Cavill also
recently spoke with Looper about Enola
Holmes too and admitted that during
filming he and actress Millie Bobby
Brown indulged in some improvisational
work on set he said in the interview yes
there was plenty of improvising there
were things that don't make the cut
sometimes and there was plenty of stuff
done there which was a lot of fun to do
but not fitting for the pace or the
moment and how they want to present it
but lots of improv the script was very
much a shell which we worked from and
Millie's a wonderful actor to improv
with
now that's called dedicating yourself to
the art of acting
[Music]